[Music]
oklet's video it plays music you can
even look at your photos plus it has
Wi-Fi built-in so you can surf the web
and download more content but it's not
an iPod the Archos 605 Wi-Fi and it
beats the pants off of any other media
player we've tested this year let's
start with the screening not even the
iPhone can come close to the Archos as
4.3 inch screens its resolution is 800
by 480 pixels which actually is more
resolution than a standard definition
television so it's not quite HD but it's
still really really good new video looks
amazing on this screen it's also touch
sensitive so it keeps the interface
really clean and simple it comes with a
stylus but unless you have sort of
massive Hulk Hogan size hands you're not
really going to need it you just use
your fingers to control it along the
right side of the unit there are these
six buttons that help you quickly
navigate through things get you right
back up to the home screen and even let
you control the volume right from the
front the Archos has Wi-Fi built-in
which means it's really easy to browse
websites or download other content and
when you need to type a URL an on-screen
keyboard just pops up and it's pretty
easy to use it recognizes where you're
pressing pretty accurately one thing is
a drag though and that is you have to
pay more for some extras so if you want
our web browser 30 bucks
you want an internet radio plug-in
that's another 20 or a calendar widget
and some games that's 20 more you know
they're great functions but it feels a
little bit like Arcos is nickel and
diming you hear one cool thing is the
Archos can record TV shows although
you're going to need either their video
doc which is another hundred dollars or
the travel adapter which is 70 once
you've got the accessories it's really
easy to set up like a TiVo you just plug
it in and use the menus in the channel
guide to pick the shows you want to
record you can also use the Archos as
Wi-Fi connection to download movies from
cinema now they cost $10 each and take
about an hour to download on a broadband
connection
the unit we tested was 30 gigabytes of
storage for $300 plus another 50 bucks
for the web browser and some of the
extras but we still feel like that's a
pretty good deal especially with the
beautiful screen the great industrial
design and the durability in our testing
that's why I've got a 9 out of 10 rating
and our best of test award for Wired
magazine I'm mark McCluskey
[Music]
you